consider the following story Bob is in a
room and he has two coins one fair coin
and one double sided coin he picks one
at random flips it and shouts the result
hey now what is the probability that he
flipped the fair coin to answer this
question we need only rewind and grow a
tree
the first event he picks one of two
coins so our tree grows two branches
leading to two equally likely outcomes
fair or unfair the next event he flips
the coin we grow again if he had the
fair coin we know this flip can result
in two equally likely outcomes heads and
tails while the unfair coin results in
two outcomes both heads our tree is
finished and we see it has four leaves
representing four equally likely
outcomes
the final step new evidence he says hey
whenever we gain evidence we must trim
our tree we cut any branch leading to
tails because we know tails did not
occur and that is it so the probability
that he chose the fair coin is the one
fair outcome leading to heads divided by
the three possible outcomes leading to
heads or one-third what happens if he
flips again and reports
hey remember after each event our tree
grows the fair coin leaves result in two
equally likely outcomes heads and tails
the unfair coin leaves result in two
equally likely outcomes heads and heads
after we hear the second Hey
we cut any branches leading to tails
therefore the probability the coin is
fair after two heads in a row is the one
Faro come leading to heads
divided by all possible outcome leading
to heads or 1/5 notice our confidence in
the fair coin is dropping
Moorhead's occur though realize it will
never reach zero no matter how many
flips occur we can never be 100% certain
the coin is unfair in fact all
conditional probability questions can be
solved by growing trees let's do one
more to be sure bob has three coins two
are fair one is biased which is weighted
to land heads two thirds of the time and
tails one-third he chooses a coin at
random and flips it hey now what is the
probability he chose the biased coin
let's rewind and build a tree
the first event choosing the coin can
lead to three equally likely outcomes
fair coin fair coin and unfair coin the
next event the coin is flipped
each fair coin leads to two equally
likely leaves heads and tails the biased
coin leads to three equally likely
leaves two representing heads and one
representing tails now the trick is to
always make sure our tree is balanced
meaning an equal amount of leaves
growing out of each branch to do this we
simply scale up the number of branches
to the least common multiple for two and
three this is six
and finally we label our leaves the fair
coin now splits into six equally likely
leaves three heads and three tails but
the biased coin we now have two tail
leaves and four head leaves and that is
it when Bob shouts the result
hey this new evidence allows us to trim
all branches leading to tails since
tails did not occur so the probability
that he chose the bias coin given heads
occur well four leaves can come from the
bias coin divided by all possible leaves
4/10 or 40%
when in doubt it's always possible to
answer conditional probability questions
by Bayes theorem it tells us the
probability of event a given some new
evidence B though if you forgot it no
worries
you need only know how to grow stories
with trimmed trees